The birds are about to stand up when they're hungry.
If you pull it out and rebuild it,
you'll be able to get into the cow well.
But now I'm getting overwhelming power with the effect of one-man army.
I wonder if the monkey's girlfriend is in this neighborhood because the story came out without
it.  I
didn't look like that type at
all, I'm not that type,
even after defeating it. I've stopped the character of the influence of 1 Burger Arm.
It's not
something else, but it's down.
You're fighting just for yourself and it's dirty.
I know that. I know the best.
It's too far behind anyone [music] You can win yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah